hello everyone and the welcome to a very
interesting game from round six of the
Kashima of Memorial 2018 between onigiri
and David navara so far we only covered
a couple of games and so far you've seen
in my previous videos that the only two
players who actually achieved at least
one victory were were Magnus Carlsen and
Veselin Topalov so here we have a very
interesting turn of events but before we
see the actual game I have some I have a
very important announcement I have to
share with you here just check this out
it's a letter I received today it's from
YouTube but you don't have to read it I
did I did prepare like a digital version
of it so for any of you who are
interested in reading what it says
you're very welcome to pause the video
and do so so I will give it a couple of
seconds for you to decide maybe you want
to read it there you can see it's signed
by Susan the CEO of YouTube so that's
the letter and with the letter I also
received something else so here it is
you can check it out it even has a even
has a mirror there you can see it here
it's the YouTube silver play button here
you can see it's very hard to actually
get it but it says presented to agamotto
for passing 100,000 subscribers from
YouTube so very nice I decided not to do
the the unboxing video of the button
since every button is the same only only
your name is different on it so it's not
like it's gonna be a surprise what's
inside but they're just so you know I
did get it it you know they said it
would come in about six to ten weeks but
it actually arrived in three days so
that was kind of cool but now back to
the game and I did prepare some
interesting statistics after this game
for you Gary has the white pieces and he
opens with E for navara plays c6 so we
have the caro-kann defense a very
interesting since we covered a lot of
Kharak on defenses during our series at
all versus both mimic d4 d5 and the gear
goes for a 5 the advanced variation
Bishop to a5 we have Knight to f3 d6 and
Bishop to e2 c5
losing the temple but it's it's an
important move to play Bishop to e3 and
Queen to b6 and here it goes for Knight
to c3 generously offering the b2 pawn
now can the B to pawn actually be
captured well let's grab it and see if
Queen capture some b2 of course nice the
b5 is what follows the thread is Knight
to c7 attacking the king and the rook so
only defense basically is nice to a6 you
could also go King d8 but you know you
don't want to move your king unless
unless it's necessary but then after D
captures on c5 Bishop captures on c5 you
can simply Castle black is never gonna
capture here on e3 he doesn't want to
allow this Bishop to d6 check and it
would be very hard to play this for
black you have to develop the other
night also on the edge of the board so
naturally something you want to do and
if you go 97 then you allow Knight to d6
ad this would this would be very hard to
play if Bishop captures pawn captures
and it's questionable if you can even
move this Knight if you move the knight
then Ruby 1 is coming
d7 with check rook is coming capturing
the b7 pawn with check a black is
falling apart here so you know it's not
not something you would recommend
capturing the B to bond so Knight to c6
Knight to a4 now attacking the Queen
Queen to a5 check and now c3 you could
also go Knight back to c3 but that's
that's not really something you want to
do
so instead c3 we have a pawn captures on
d4 Knight captures on d4 and Knight
captures on d4 Bishop captures on d4 and
Knight to e7 castles by Gary nice to see
6 and we have B for now attacking the
Queen Queen c7 and rook to c1 and here
you might think it seems like a very
nice idea to grab this Bishop then the
b4 pawn is very weak and while this
might be true it's it's really not
because after Knight captures pawn
captures your queen is now attacked you
have to do something about this and
after you play something like Queen to
d7 now ok you attack the knight on e4
and also the b4 point is still attacked
but after Knight to c3 you can't capture
the before point unfortunately if you
capture Daniel
to be 5 and you lose the Queen and the
game so after work 2 c1 and we have
Bishop to e7 g for now
the bayonet move it's not the bayonet
variation but I know in any advance
variation of the kurakin I like to call
the g4 move the bayonets
so Bishop to b4 f3 attacking the bishop
the bishop moves again and now F for
preparing f5 so Bishop back to e4
we have nice the c5 and now a5 a5 you
could also you could also maybe capture
the night but then Bishop captures and
it will be a very annoying Bishop you
could never Castle so a 5
we have Bishop to e3 and now pawn
captures on b4 C capture some before and
rook to a3 this was a very interesting
idea rook to a3 as the bishop on e3 is
undefended but it's also a very nice
position for you to stop the video and
see why bush rook captures an a2 is not
possible or maybe it is possible you
don't feel free to pause the video and
check it out so for those of you who
decided to pause the video
congratulations
if you decided that it's not okay to
capture the rook if you captured the
rock then the simple Knight captures on
e4 wins the game because after D
captures you get b5 and the knight is
pinned or so rockin c1 you lose the
piece no point in no point in continuing
this game so after the seek after some
before Navarro tried rook to a3 going
for the bishop on e3 Bishop to f2 was
played and now Bishop captures on c5
Bishop captures on c5 and this is now an
excellent position for Geary this Bishop
is slicing all the way here not allowing
Navarre asking the castle and b5 would
be a terrible threat this would attack
the knight and also open up the attack
from this bishop to the rook on a3 so
you don't have to play something here
and it's not all that easy to decide
what here Navarro did capture the pawn
on a two and he did allow this b5 move
but b5 is not such a big big idea now
because well there's no rock on a3
that's under attack and here you you
have to play nice to a5
but even after Knight to a5 Bishop to d6
is coming and then after Queen moves
this comes with the check it's very hard
to decide what to do you can bring
Bishop to Bishop back to c5 which would
kind of be an offer for a repetition of
moves which could result in a draw since
you know this is a Giri playing he might
even go for this cetera you know a
repetition like this but after this b5
move Bishop to c2 was played and this is
a move that basically characterizes this
game Bishop to Bishop - see - and what
do you play now the knight on c6 is
still under attack and what's the idea
why didn't have our play Bishop to see -
one possible idea is that he saw rook
captures rook captures and then he saw
that the Queen cannot capture the rook
because if Queen captures then comes the
ninth to d4 and now your Bishop on e2 is
attacked the Queen is attacking the
bishop on c5 the bishop cannot capture
the knight on d4 because the Queen will
be hanging on c2 and you have to play a
move here sorry about that
if you play Queen c3 or Queen c1 then
Bishop captures any two checks the King
and the wins the Queen as the knight it
is covering both of those squares so
it's very hard to find a move after
something like Queen to f4 you do lose
the bishop here and after King G to
Queen captures on c5 so you'd be up a
piece for a moment but after Queen
checks King moves and Queen captures on
h8 it's white who's up the exchange but
after something like Queen c2 it would
end in a draw you have to go away with
the King and then Queen c3 check King
goes back and then it will be a
repetition of moves if you try something
like this then 24 will even be winning
for black but it's very hard to say how
much of this did Navarre see or analyze
because after this Bishop to see to move
the problem is after rook captures rook
captures the giri doesn't have to
immediately capture the rook he can
simply play b6 and then and it's game
over immediately
because now if if the Queen moves we get
the exact same position we had before so
know for example Queen see it now Queen
captures on c2
nice the d4 is no longer possible if
Knight to d4 now which was the idea
before now there is no longer pawn and
b5 Queen a4 check and you know like we
just Black is just losing you have to go
back and then there should be five
simply pinning it
Geary would be up a piece in a
completely winning position but this is
why I called the video a lazy variation
after this Bishop to see to move Geary
didn't talk maybe he was too lazy to
calculate all of this but it doesn't
really matter because he saw that the
immediate b6 is his justice winning
because now if you play something like
Queen to c8 we get the exact same
variation we had rock captures captures
captures and then Knight to d4 is
useless but it's it might be a slightly
lesser move in in terms of maybe the
strength of moves but it doesn't matter
for you know it's efficient it's it's a
very nice human a very nice lazy human
move because now he did a lot of
captures Queen on d1 so we're here we
have Punk after screen on c7 and of
course now Gary saw that black doesn't
have time to stop upon to c8 Queen and
capturing of the bishop at the same time
so he would definitely win a piece at
the end of this variation so uh Gary
decided this was okay he played this b6
move with this idea and we have king to
d7 by Navarro and Bishop captures on D 1
so gear is now up a piece we have King
captures on c7 and Bishop to d6 check
King to d7 and now rook to be won and it
was in this position after loop to be
one that David navara resigned the game
why did he resign
well he's down a piece and he really
doesn't have any counter play he does
have two two points for the piece but he
you can't really defend this the b7
point is under attack you have to do
something if you play Knight here then
you get rook to be four and there's
really nothing black can do Bishop to a4
is is coming with check and after black
plays any move for example f6 now comes
the bishop to a4 check and you have to
give up the rook if you try and run away
then you're getting checkmated Roxy one
check tonight blocks captures captures
captures he moves checks
1087 and
see seven this will be checkmate or or
black will run into some severe material
loss so yeah after this work to be won
David Navarro resigned the game and a
first victory for onigiri in in the
gushy move Memorial 2018 and I did say I
prepared some nice statistics for you so
here is their overall a lifetime record
so far onigiri beat David Navarro 3 to 0
with six Ross so they played nine games
so far giving one three six of them were
drawn so a very nice result by Gary and
you know might be might be one of the
reasons one of our played the bishop C
to move he just got too nervous playing
against Gary as he never he never even
drew I he never won a game against him
so yeah that's one of one of the things
and another thing is here are the
standings after round six of the Kashima
memorial still in first place Veselin
Topalov with four out of six only player
which to win so far in the tournament
magnus carlsen and onigiri both with
three and a half points both of them
with one win and then all of the other
players who so far have not yet achieved
a single winner Ralph Mahmoud of Sergey
Carrick in Bingley Renta murder job of
rather Slava taschek Shockley are mamita
Aravind Davi Navarro now in last place
after losing this game against Gary so
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
I would like to thank Mattie she managed
for a contribution to my channel thanks
a lot - really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and
that we'll see you soon hopefully with
another interesting video thank you